Most of the time we
don't have the luxury
of showing the various
points of view,
so we have to find the
right point of view
when we are submitting to
journals or presentations.
So here's an image that I
made of a microreactor that
studies a particular reaction.
It was important to show how
this microreactor was connected
to the analytic
pieces, and so here's
another point of view
showing the pieces connected
to the background.
So I worked a little
more on this; was there
a way to show the microreactor
with the background
pieces at an angle?
This was OK.
I wanted to see a little
more of the front of it,
and so I went to
try for this one.
Notice, something
isn't quite right.
I hope you are
getting more and more
particular with your own images.
You see something up
here in the corner.
That's this shadow.
We don't want that.
So by moving the camera
just a little more
to a different angle,
we get a cleaner image.
I wanted to play around a little
bit with the microreactor,
this particular one, on its
own, and then what I did
was I duplicated it, put a
digital background on it.
I thought it would be
kind of interesting.
Maybe it could be used
for an introduction slide.
Bottom line is the
researchers never used it.
So went back to the
clear documentary
image, which hopefully really
shows what is going on here,
and, indeed, we did get
it published as a cover
and, also, of course,
in the figure.
This is the best point of view
for this particular device.